en pleine crise du convoi des
camionneurs des résidents d'Ottawa avait
pris les choses en main bloquant un pont
pour empêcher les manifestants d'entrer
au centre-ville
un an plus tard des résidents ont
installé une plaque commémorative pour
se souvenir de ce qu'ils ont surnommé la
bataille du pont beelings cette plaque
commémore les gens ordinaires qui ont
fait quelque chose d'extraordinaire
alors que leur dirigeants ne faisait
rien pouvait-on lire avant qu'elle ne
soit retirée
[Musique]
une preuve des tensions qui persiste
encore aujourd'hui dans la communauté
[Musique]
l'un des derniers chapitres de la crise
et sur le point de s'écrire le rapport
final de la Commission sur l'état
d'urgence les pilogues d'un véritable
feuilleton
les audiences offriront un processus
impartial prononcer le mot comme farfad
et
c'est un niveau
de de manifestations de frustration et
d'agression
pendant six semaines de dédience le
portrait d'une crise chaotique et sans
précédent
des services policiers débordés
désorganisés et paralysés pendant des
semaines face à des manifestants
organisés et bien financés les dons au
convoi qui n'ont pas été gelés étaient
redistribués au camionneur à coups
notamment
[Musique]
la veille de l'invocation des mesures
d'urgence après deux semaines de crise
la commissaire de la GRC croyait que
d'autres options étaient disponibles les
forces de l'ordre avaient élaboré un
plan pour libérer le centre-ville mais
elle n'en a pas parlé explicitement avec
le gouvernement Trudeau
je ne crois pas que cela aurait changé
quoi que ce soit à tel témoigner après
avoir consulté le Conseil des ministres
Justin Trudeau a évoqué les mesures
d'urgence le 14 février
je peux dire qu'on est sorti avec un
consensus clair les pouvoirs spéciaux
permettaient de forcer le remorquage
d'un camion de geler des comptes
bancaires ou d’interdire les
déplacements vers certains lieux
stratégiques tour à tour les ministres
sont venus défendre cette mesure
extraordinaire
à la frontière sur l'économie canadienne
où les risques à la sécurité publique
arme à feu saisie à toute son Alberta
manifestant aux idéologies extrémistes
présence d'enfants craintes d'attaque de
loup solitaire le Premier ministre a
insisté la réponse du gouvernement était
proportionnelle à la menace la situation
était si urgente avait un une
préoccupation que ça pourrait se
s'empirer dégringoler mais le patron du
service canadien du renseignement de
sécurité ne croyez pas que le convoi
atteignait le seuil d'une menace à la
sécurité nationale au sens de la loi une
définition étroite qui gagnerait à être
modernisé selon le numéro 1 des services
secrets looking
[Musique]
doit revenir en arrière déterminer si le
gouvernement Trudeau a bien utilisé les
pouvoirs spéciaux mais il doit aussi
regarder vers la vente Paul rouleau
pourrait recommander des modifications à
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence pour
mieux encadrer son utilisation dans le
futur cela pourrait devenir l'impact
durable de la commission ou de la des
conséquences politiques ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada
Ottawa
[Musique]